I want to get to another voter.
Caitlin Bolzano is a student here
at Saint Anselm College.
She's a Republican.
This will be the first election
that she has voted in.
What's your question
for the president, Caitlin?
Hello, President Trump,
thank you so much for coming. Thank you.
The current administration
has made it clear
that we should continue
to provide military equipment to Ukraine
so that they can defend themselves.
Do you support this decision?
And how would you deal with
the increasing threat
posed by Vladimir Putin?
First of all, thank you very much.
It's really nice
and it's an important question.
So important
because we're giving away
so much equipment.
We don't have ammunition for ourselves
right now.
We don't have ammunition for ourselves.
We're giving away so much.
But here's the thing.
I have to say it.
To start off, no longer matters.
If I were president,
this would have never happened.
And even the Democrats
admit that Putin knew
it would have never happened
and his pipeline
would have never happened.
A lot of things
would have never happened,
but this would never have happened.
All those dead people,
both Russian and Ukrainian,
it would they wouldn't be dead today.
And all those cities
that are blown up
and disintegrated right to the ground,
that wouldn't have happened.
Okay.
Now, here's the problem
we've given so far, $171 billion.
They've given meaning
they meaning European Union,
which is approximately
the same size altogether as our economy.
They've given about 20.
So we're at 170, let's say,
and there are 20.
You don't have to know
too much about history
to realize where geography
to realize
that they're
a little bit more effective than we are.
Okay.
So they've got to put up a lot more money
because they're taking advantage of us
like every other country.
That's why
I ended NAFTA
and replace it with the USMCA in Mexico.
On this issue, Mr.
President,
I should note
I don't know any Democrats
who have said they don't believe
Putin would have invaded
if you were president.
But her question is,
would you continue to give
Ukraine money and weapons
if you're elected? What's the answer?
I have a very good relationship with
President Zelenskiy because, as you know,
he backed me up with the with the phony
impeachment impeachment hoax number one,
when he said
the president didn't do anything wrong.
So I caught him.
But so I happened to like.
Yeah, that's right.
And it was
I was totally exonerated, by the way.
Just a waste of time and money.
You were impeached over that.
You're for that.
But let's stay on topic here, Mr.
President, because the question is,
what do you give Ukraine?
What was your speech by a crazy woman
named Nancy Pelosi?
Here is,
would you give Ukraine weapons
and funding if you or I would sit down?
Let me just put it this way.
If I'm president, I will have
that war settled in one day, 24 hours.
How would you settle that war in one day?
First, I'll meet with Putin.
I'll meet with Zelensky.
They both have weaknesses
and they both have strengths.
And within 24 hours,
that war will be settled. It'll be over.
It'll be absolutely to Ukraine
to win this war.
I don't think
in terms of winning and losing,
I think in terms of getting it settled.
So we stop
killing all these people
and breaking them is.
Now,
what do you.
Can I just follow up on that?
You said you don't think
you have to do things.
You have to get
you have to follow up on that
because that's
a really important position.
Let me just follow there.
Can you say if you want Ukraine
or Russia to win this war?
I want everybody to stop dying.
They're dying.
Russians and Ukrainians.
I want us to stop dying.
And I'll have that done.
I'll have that done in 24 hours.
I'll have it done.
You need the power of the presidency
to do it,
but you won't say that
you want Ukraine to win you.
You know what I'll say?
I'll say this.
I want Europe to put up more money
because they're in for 20 billion.
We're in for 170.
And they should be
and they should equalize.
They have plenty of money.
They should equalize.
I got with Naito
when I sat down, I got them to put up
hundreds
of billions of dollars
that they weren't
paying under Obama and Bush
and all of these other presidents.
That's why
they're able to help them fight the war
because of the money I got.
But I want Europe happening in excuse me.
I want Europe to put up more money
because they're laughing at us.
They think we're a bunch of jerks.
We're spending $170 billion
for faraway land,
and they're right next door to that land
and they're in for 20.
I don't think so.
When it comes to what's happening there.
When you were in office,
you said that you respected
President Putin.
I still respect him today.
He made a tremendous mistake,
made him that his smart guy.
You know, I remember I said he was smart.
She was what they said.
He said President Xi of China.
Right. Is smart.
Okay. 1.5 billion people.
He's the ruler of 1.5 billion people.
I said he's a smart guy.
How dare he say he's smart?
Of course he's smart.
They want you to say he's
a stupid person.
He's not a stupid person is very smart.
He's very cunning.
And Putin
made a bad mistake, in my opinion.
What was his his mistake was going in.
He would have never gone in
if I was president.
We used to talk about ourselves.
Do you believe that he is a war criminal?
But do you believe
that Putin is a war criminal?
He's responsible for
the deaths of thousands?
Well, I think this
I think it's something
that should not be discussed now.
It should be discussed later,
because right now we have to go to war.
If you say he's a war
criminal, it's going to be a lot tougher
to make a deal to get this thing stopped.
Because if he's going to be a war
criminal, what people are going to go
and grab him and execute him.
He's going to fight a lot
harder than he's fighting.
You know,
under the other circumstance,
that's something to be discussed
at a later
date is right now
we want to get that war settled.
And I'm
not talking about the money either.
I'm talking about all the lives
that are being
the number of people being killed in
that war is far greater than you hear
when they blow up the city
and those buildings come pouring down
and they say two people were injured.
No, no.
Hundreds
and thousands of people are being killed
and we have to get that war settled.